didier bourdon alors tout arnaud
parlions de cette de cette séparation du
classique et du moderne qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous et pourquoi ce choix
pourquoi avoir choisi plutôt lettre la
classe traditionnelle que la glace la
classe moderne et bien disons que la
classe traditionnelle offre la
possibilité de passer un concours en fin
d'année qui n'a plus lieu dans la classe
ce soit en classe moderne ont lieu des
journées en trois jours et la crise
traditionnelle a droit à une journée où
se déroule le concours et vous pensez
que ça change grand chose
non je pense pas disons que ce qui est
bien c'est que il y a deux formations et
le concours de la presse traditionnelle
à une journée à elle et permet d'habiter
pas mal la vie de professionnel métiers
ce qui fait qu'on se fait voir aux cils
peut-être un peu et là votre emploi vous
lier mon emploi je sais pas j'aimerais
bien trouver déjà tigo oui je pense que
des fausses questions est ce que c'est
un vrai problème
je pense que je ne pourrais pas jouer
bien sûr un personnage de 50 ans comme
je ne pourrais pas jouer je ne pourrais
plus jouer un jeune premier de molière
ou
notre auteur didier bourdon vous avez
choisi de nous dire un monologue de
molière
extraite de l'impromptu de versailles
qu'est ce qui constitue un petit peu
l'action disons que molière répond à ses
détracteurs ccnmi de l'hôtel de
bourgogne qui n'ont accusé d'inceste
ils ont accusé d'avoir épousé sa propre
fille je crois que c'est assez grave ou
même qui nous mêmes accusés d'être cocu
si on peut accuser quelqu'un d'être cocu
quant à lui a reproché du mois alors
molière répond publiquement dans
l'apprenti de versailles où il se met
lui même en scène avec sa propre troupe
un moment donné de la pièce que je vais
essayer de vous interpréter mes enfants
je ferai ma déclaration publiquement je
ne peux en faire aucune réponse à toutes
leurs critiques et leurs contres
critiques qu'ils disent tous les maux du
monde de mes pièces
j'en suis d'accord qu'il s'en saisisse
après nous qu'ils les retourne comme un
habit pour les mettre sur leur théâtre
et acheta profiter de quelques agréments
qu'on y trouve et d'un peu de bonheur
que j'ai je consens ils en ont besoin et
je serai bien aise de contribuer à les
faire subsister
pourvu qu'il se contente de ce que je
puis leur accorder avec bienséance la
courtoisie doit avoir des bornes et bien
des choses qui ne font rire ni les
spectateurs ni celui dont on parle
je leur abandonne de bon coeur mais
ouvrage ma figure mes gestes mais parole
mon ton de voix et ma façon d'errer cité
pour en faire et dire tout ce qu'il leur
plaira
si l'on peuvent tirer quelque avantage
je ne m'oppose points à toutes ces
choses et je serais ravi que cela puisse
réjouir le monde mais en leur
abandonnant tout cela il me doit faire
la grâce de me laisser le reste est de
ne pas toucher à des matières de la
nature de celles sur lesquelles on m'a
dit qu'il m'attaque est dans leur
comédie sais de quoi je prierai
civilement cet honnête monsieur qui se
mêlent d'écrire pour eux et voilà toute
la réponse qu'ils auront de moins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]